the playstation 5 reveal Levin went down
this morning which means we got our very
first look at the console itself we also
got to look at some of the games we're
gonna be seeing with that console later
this year on top of all of that modern
warfare season 4 also dropped today I'm
Persia and you've reached your safe
State for Thursday June 11th PlayStation
fans around the world have been dying to
see what the PS Vita was gonna look like
and we finally got our first sneak peek
during today's event they showed off two
separate versions a standard and a
digital with no disk drive but when it
comes to the look and feel it's tall a
white and black two-tone and I'm kind of
looks like a Wi-Fi router the stream
showed additional hardware like a
charging station a media remote a 3d
audio headset and a camera for use with
the psvr personally I think it looks
really good and very sleek and I did see
one frame of it laying horizontally
which is kinda I needed to be sold
obviously the PlayStation 5 console was
not the only thing we got to check out
today considering that the live event
was basically all about the games some
of the returning franchises and sequels
that we got to check out we're a Spider
Man Miles Morales hitman three Resident
Evil 8 and horizon forbidden West there
were even some games that we saw in
there for the very first time like stray
destruction all-stars then the Demon
Souls remake there were even some games
that we knew about that were confirmed
for PS 5 but got to see more of like
little devil inside God fall in death
loop personally I really really want to
play kena
I love the trailer and it looked so
beautiful but there were a ton of
reveals that I didn't even get a chance
to mention here so you already know just
go to gamespot.com and check out our
entire roundup put together by our very
own Tony Wilson there wasn't any Cod
news during the PS 5 reveal event but
that doesn't mean that there isn't any
Cod news to talk about because modern
warfare season 4 is officially live
season 4 is gonna land you three new
multiplayer maps for modern warfare
including a brand-new one for ground war
and gun fight
also gonna land you some new gamemodes
from modern warfare and war zone with
modes like one in the chamber
all-or-nothing jailbreak and a fire sale
coming to your playlists but also war
zone is adding supply choppers which are
non-lethal but heavily armored which
should shake things up with it now the
update is gonna be massive it wouldn't
be a cod one if it wasn't so be prepared
for that and of course if you want any
more details about this update then you
just gotta go to GameSpot calm and of
course you guys please don't forget that
we are smack dab in the middle of play
for all which is our multi week event
that's gonna be the best place for you
to get all the latest gaming news
interviews features and more kind of
like the PS 5 event that we watch this
morning the best part is is that it's
all for a charitable cons we've already
raised thousands of dollars for black
lives matter and Cove in nineteen relief
efforts and we're hoping with the help
of you guys to keep that going through
the rest of the summer that's a wrap on
the news for Thursday June 11th I'm
Persia and you can follow me on twitter
at persia underscore XO and make sure
you reach your stage date on monday with
curtains i'll see you guys next time